my guest tonight is a five-time Emmy
award-winning journalist who was the
anchorman for kvwn Channel 4 News in San
Diego please welcome Ron Burgundy
[Applause]
please I don't know what you were saying
but it was lovely let me just ask you do
we got any people here from out of town
we'll stay out of town okay because we
don't need you allies crowded enough no
but seriously
lately I've been doing some stand-up
comedy and well I'm really enjoying it
I'm finding out I'm quite good at it
and I brought along my my trunk of
tricks here would you would you like to
take a peek let me let me ask you guys
something do you guys like computers I
mean well if you do then check out this
mousepad
it's a small house for the mouse inside
of it okay oh look it's a what do we
have here okay oh yeah yeah that's
special pair of glasses for you teens
out there so you never miss a LinkedIn
request we are on a roll we are on a
roll right now don't lose the momentum
Ron keep it going
stay focused hey check it out I'm on
Facebook okay that one didn't go as well
let's get him back with this one
well hear about the the new farting
Russian leader his name is Vladimir
tootin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right what else we got here oh yeah
now we're talking oh no that's not right
you guys a Laker fans we got any Laker
fans you like Shaquille O'Neal that's a
real that's real veal that's good stuff
oh my god that's good
that is good that's a good chop right
there oh hey here's a game for dumb
people like everyone in this crowd
it's called connect to
[Laughter]
okay fans of my favorite city will love
this
it's called sandy egg oh yeah yeah okay
I didn't organize my trunk um and for
all the comic book nerds out there it's
Iron Man here's something okay here's a
little joke I I don't like to do because
it's a little corny but look there's
corn and O'Brien
few people don't know Dominic he's got
his buddy here's Andy Brickner
unhappiness oh the gloves are hot and
this one no this is to court this is
stupid I'm not gonna do that one okay oh
here's a little hat this is buddy I
entered a hat contest I was I was the
Wiener no one else could catch up I
relished it
[Applause]
and finally the next time I need to drop
a couple kids off at the pool I want a
ride in style
Marcedes engineering it so you know it's
good anyway thanks folks you've been a
great audience
oh my that sounds okay